Obama Romney who's more committed to
minding other people's business who's
got your vote for any of the month
special interactive election edition
drug war both say I pot legalization
both say nay Romney's against medical
marijuana and the former Qin gang toker
continues to SiC federal agents on
dispensaries did you inhale that was the
point Obamacare's got that individual
mandate the same theme it stuck the bay
state with the guns signed a statewide
smoking ban in Obama's Recovery Act
stimulated local smoking bans hey wait a
second we have civil liberties we have
to worry about Patriot Act warrantless
surveillance National Defense
Authorization Act indefinite detention
they both back all of it Romney opposes
gay marriage Obama's all foreign as of
this year Obama has cracked down on
online poker don't expect Romney can be
any better the press hearts with
censorship Romney promises to punish
pornographers then again the queen of
porn has gotten behind MIT and Obama
busted buckyballs so who's your nanny
America click the screen to vote for the
candidate you think is the biggest busy
party
you